ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw@mit.edu
PROFESSOR: So today we're
going to cover a data structure
called link-cut trees.
A cool way of maintaining
dynamic trees,
and it begins our study
of dynamic graphs.
Where in general, we have
a graph usually undirected.
You want to support insertion
and deletion of edges.
So we're going to do that in
the situation where at all times
our graphs are trees.
So in general, we
have a forest of trees
and we want to maintain them.
So that will be our only
data structure today
because it's a bit complicated.
It's going to need some
fancy amortization.
And two techniques
for splitting trees
into paths, one
we've seen already
in the context of tango
trees and lecture's
six, preferred paths.
And another, which
we haven't seen
is probably my favorite
technique in data structures,
actually, heavy
like decomposition.
The technique and data structure
that I've used the most
outside of data structures.
It's very useful in
lots of settings.
Whenever you have
an unbalanced tree
and you want to make it balance,
like with like cut trees,
It's the go to tool.
So, in, general we want to
maintain a forest of trees.
And these are going to be
rooted unordered trees.
So arbitrary degree I this.
And we have a bunch of
operations we want to do.
Basically, insertion and
deletion of edges and some
queries.
And we want to do all
of those operations
in the log n time per operation.
That's the hard part.
So we have some kind of getting
started operation make tree.
This is going to be make a new
vertex in a new tree, return.
It.
So this is how you add
notes to the structure.
And we're not going to
worry about doing deletions.
Once you add something
it stays there forever.
So you could you could do that.
It's no big deal.
You could throw away a tree.
Then we have link
which is essentially
the insertion of an edge.
So here we're given
two vertices BMW
that are in different
trees as a precondition.
So v has to be at
the root of its tree.
W can be any node.
So here we have another tree
and we have some node w inside v
And the link operation
adds V as a child of W.
So we add this edge.
OK, that, of course, combines
two trees into one tree.
And the requirement is BMW
has to be in different trees
or otherwise you'd be
adding a cycle that
doesn't satisfy that were
always a forest of trees.
Then we have a cut operation,
which is basically the reverse.
So let me draw it.
We have V subtree parent.
And there is a
whole tree up here.
And what we want to do
is remove that edge.
So that splits one tree into
two trees by the leading
edge from V to its parent.
OK so those are our updates.
Pretty obvious in the
setting of dynamic graphs.
Of course, it's the
first time we see them.
Now we have some queries.
There are lots of
different queries
that cut-trees can support.
One of the most basic is
find the root of vertex.
Let me just draw a picture of.
It you have some
vertex V, you want
to return the root of the tree.
So find R. And that's
pretty easy to do.
Well actually see it in
next class, next lecture,
if you wanted to make
tree/link cut and find root,
there's a really easy way to
do them in logarithmic time.
link-cut trees is a harder
way to do it in log n time,
but they support a lot
of other operations.
And in particular, something
called path aggregation.
This is kind of the essence
of link/cut are cool.
Let's suppose you
have a for a tree,
you have a vertex V.
There's a root to V path.
And let's suppose that every
node or every edge, doesn't
matter, has a weight on it.
Just some real number.
Then path aggregation
can do things
like the min or
the max or the sum
or the product or whatever
of weights on that path.
And this is a powerful thing.
And it's actually the reason
link/cut trees were originally
invented for doing network
flow algorithms faster.
If you know network
flow algorithms.
Or maybe you've seen them
in advanced algorithms.
This is sort of the key
thing you need to do.
You find, I think, min way
edge along one of these paths
and that's the max you can push
in a push reliable strategy.
I don't want to get into that
because that's algorithms, not
data structures.
But this is why
they were invented.
And, in general, link/cut
trees have a very strong kind
of path thing.
If you want to know
anything about a root
to the path for any
node v, link-cut trees
can do whatever you
want in lon n time.
This is just sort of
an example of that.
And Yeah.
course.
So that's what link
countries are able to do.
All these operations in log
n And the main point here
is that the trees are storing
are probably not balanced.
It could be a path,
could be depth
and is this path we're talking
about could be length order
n is really bad.
And yet, we can do all these
operations in log n time.
And we're going to
do that, essentially,
by storing the unbalanced
tree that you're
trying to represent, which we
call this the represent tree.
We're going to store it using,
essentially, a balanced tree.
In one version of
link-cut trees,
indeed, we store all the
nodes in a log n height tree.
The version we're
going to cover here--
there's several versions
of link-cut trees.
Original are biased
later in Tarjan in 1983.
And then Tarjan wrote a
book, one of a few books
on data structures.
Very thin book, usually called
Tarjan's little book, in 1984.
And it has a different
version of link-cut trees,
and that's the
version we're going
to cover it uses splay
trees as a subroutine.
So it's not going to
be perfectly balanced.
It's going to be balanced
in an amortize sense,
or vaguely balanced,
roughly balanced, whatever.
But there is a version that does
everything in log n worse case
pre-operation.
If there's time, I'll sketch
that for you at the end.
But the simplest version I know
is this splay tree version.
And it's also kind of fun
because the version we'll see,
doesn't really look
like it should work,
and yet it does thanks to
splay trees, essentially.
So it's a little, it's fun
and surprising in that sense.
As I said, link-cut trees are
all about paths in the tree.
And so somehow we want to
split a tree up into paths
and we've already
seen a way to do this.
The preferred path
decomposition.
So it's kind of reminding
you, but I'm also
going to slightly redefine
it, if I recall correctly.
It's just a minor
difference which
I can talk about a second.
The notion of a preferred
child of a node, and it's
going to be two cases.
There isn't a preferred
child, if the last access
in these subtree is v. So
we have some node v. Now,
this is relative to
the represented tree.
So we have some node to v.
We don't care about accesses
outside of that subtree, but
of the last access within
the subtree was v itself, then
there's no preferred child.
Otherwise, the last
access within the tree
was in one of these
child subtrees.
And whichever one it was, we
say w is the preferred child.
So if the last access in
v subtree is in child w's
subtree.
OK, I think last time we
defined preferred children
in the context of tango trees,
we just had the second part.
So if there is an access
to v, we ignored it
and we just consider what
the last child access.
Was I don't think
there's actually
would affect tango
trees, but I think
it does effect Link-cut trees.
So I want to define it this way.
It'll make life
cleaner, basically.
Probably not a huge
difference either way.
OK, once you have
preferred children,
that gives you one outgoing
edge, downward edge,
from every node.
And so we get preferred
paths by repeatedly following
preferred child pointers.
Now, we may stop at some
point because we reach a none.
I'm going to use none as like
null pointers in this lecture.
But, in general, we have some
tree and you follow for a while
and then it's going to be a
bunch of things like this.
We decompose the nodes
and the represented tree,
partition the nodes.
Every node belongs to
some preferred path.
So basic idea is we're
going to store the preferred
paths in kind of balanced binary
search trees, splay trees,
and then we're going to connect
them together because that's
not all the edges in the tree.
There's some edges that
sort of connect them,
connect the paths together.
That's where the
tree part comes in.
That's what we're going to do
it this thing is unbalanced.
We're going to take each
of these white lines
and compress it
into a splay tree,
and preserve the red pointers.
I'll write that down.
These are called
auxiliary trees.
This was exactly the
idea and tango trace
and I'm using tango
tree terminology
to keep it consistent
with that notation.
It wasn't called preferred paths
in the link-cut tree papers.
Or it wasn't called auxiliary
trees, but same difference.
So auxiliary trees were going to
store represent each preferred
path by a splay tree.
Tango trees we use
red-black trees or whatever.
Could us splay trees,
actually, if you
use tango trees with splay
trees for each preferred path.
It's called a multi-splay tree.
Multi-splay trees are almost
identical to link-cut trees
but, they're used for
a different setting.
The use for proving
log n competitiveness.
Here we're doing it to
represent a specific tree.
With tango trees, the
tree we're representing
was just a perfect
binary tree, p.
So you may recall, here
it has some meaning.
And it's going to
be changing, and we
care about how it's changing.
OK, another difference is
we're going to key the nodes
by depth.
This is what we wanted
to do with tango trees,
but we weren't allowed
to because we had
to be a binary search trees.
And the keys were given to us.
Here, there are no keys.
So we need to specify them
and the most convenient one
is by depth.
So we're just taking a path
like this, 0, 1, 2, 3 4.
And then we're turning it
into a nice balance tree
like this, 0, 1, 2, 3, 3, 4.
OK, Now, it's a splay
trees so it's not
guaranteed to be
balanced at any moment,
but amortized is going to have
log n performance preparation.
OK, and then this
is sort of that's
representing each of
these white paths,
but then we also need
the red pointers.
So what we're going
to do is say the root
of each auxiliary
tree, I'll abbreviate
ox tree, stores what I'll
call the path parent, which
are these red pointers.
The definition is this is, the
paths, the top nodes, parent,
and represented tree.
OK, very soon it's
going to get confusing
and I'm going to always
make it explicit.
Am I talking about the
represented tree the thing
we're trying to represent?
Or am I talking about auxiliary
trees because notion of parent
is different in the two?
So in an auxiliary
tree a parent is just
whatever it happens to be
stored in the splay tree.
When you splay operations
you care about those parents.
When you're thinking
about the tree you're
trying to represent,
you care about parents
in the represented tree.
Now, how do you see that here?
Well following parent is like
doing predecessor over here.
So we kind of know
how to do predecessor
in a binary search tree.
But when we get to 0,
which is the left most
node in this tree, corresponds
to the top of the path,
if we want to do the parent
that's going up from this path,
that's going to be
the path parent.
And it saying the
path's top node,
that's this guy 0, its parent
and the representative tree
are just going to
store that pointer.
The only weird
thing is we're not
going to store the
pointer here, we're
going to store the pointer here.
That's the path parent.
We're going to put it at
the root of the splay tree,
basically because
it's really easy
to get to the root of a tree.
You could probably
start here, you just
have to go left every time
and it's kind of annoying.
Analysis will get messier.
So we'll put at the root.
And so, in particular,
if I do a rotation,
like if I rotate the tree like
this and make one the route,
that path parent pointer
has to move to 1.
But it's still
representing essentially
for this whole splay
tree representing
this path, what was the
parent pointer from there.
So this is the represented
tree, and this is the ox tree.
OK, now if I take all the
ox trees plus these parent
pointers, I get something
called the tree of ox trees.
And this is our representation.
So there's the represented
thing versus our representation.
I'm not going to use the word
representation because it
sounds almost like represented.
So it's going to be represented
versus tree of ox trees.
Tree of ox trees
is what we store,
represented is what
we want to store.
That's what we're
trying to represent.
So that's the
terminology, Basically, we
want the tree of ox
trees to be balanced,
and if there's splay trees,
they'll be kind of balanced.
Whereas, the represented
tree is on balance.
Cool so now I want
to give you some code
and how we're going to
manipulate these things.
And then we'll be able
to analyze the code
and that both will
take a little while.
The main operation I'm
going to talk about
is actually just a
helper operation.
So first I want to tell you
what it is, how it works.
It's like an access
in a tango tree.
With tango trees we just
wanted to touch item xi
and then go onto the
next item, xi plus 1.
So I'm going to think
about that world,
while all I'm trying
to do is touch nodes.
What's interesting
about touching nodes
is it changes this notion
of preferred edges.
So, as I said, the last
access in that subtree
was blah, blah, blah.
So access.
In reality, what I
mean is the last time
that node was used as a link
or cut or find operation.
But in fact I'm going
to make that explicit.
Every operation is going to
start by calling this function
access on its arguments.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I still
don't understand.
When you say that this
[INAUDIBLE] by depth--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you
go from that path
to the actual splay tree?
PROFESSOR: OK so the
transformation from this path
in the represented
tree to splay tree
is just these nodes have
depth within that path,
I mean they're just
stored along the path.
What I mean is, I want to store
them in as a binary search
tree ordered by that value.
So that's what-- yeah.
So splay trees have
some key on the nodes,
they maintain the binary
search tree property.
My key is just going
to be the depth.
The position along the path.
AUDIENCE: So if you do an
in order traversal you just
get the path.
PROFESSOR: Right if I do
it in order traversal here,
I'll get the path back.
Yep, no problem.
That's going to be
important to understand.
OK, so to do an access, access
is going to do two things.
The first thing it has to
do, and the other thing
is going to make our
life easy, you'll
see once we've defined access,
all operations become trivial.
So it's going to be a
really cool helper function.
The first thing we have to
do, when we access a node v,
is say well that then by
definition the path to v from
the root --v to root I guess,
sort of, but probably more root
to v--
should be preferred.
That's the definition
of preferred
because now it's the
latest thing accessed.
So we've got to fix that.
But we're going to
do a little bit more
we're also going to make
v the root of its ox tree.
Which will mean, because
that ox tree is now
the top most ox tree because
that actually contains the root
and it contains v. So
in fact, v is the root
of the tree of ox trees.
It's the overall root for
this tree of our streets.
Why do we do that?
Well, it's sort of going to
just be a consequence of using
splay, because whenever
you splice something
you move it to the root
in this zigzaggy way.
But it will actually be really
helpful to have this property,
and that's why these are the
simplest link-cut trees I know.
OK, so how do we do this?
So you're given the node
v somewhere in this world,
and we've basically got to
fix a lot of preferred child
pointers.
And, whereas, tango
trees basically
walked from the top down,
navigating one preferred path
until it found the
right place to exit
and then fixing that edge, were
going to be working bottom up.
Because we already know where
the vertexes, were given it,
and we need to walk our way
up the tree and kind of push
v to the root overall.
So the first thing
to do is splay v. So
that, now, when I say splay
v, I mean within its ox tree.
Doesn't make sense to do
it in any global sense.
In some sense access is going to
be our global version of splay.
Whenever I say splay a node, I
mean just within its ox tree.
That's going to be the
definition of splay tree.
So you may recall from Lecture
Six there's the zig-zig case
and zig-zag case.
You do some rotation,
double rotation, whatever.
In the end, maybe one
more rotation, and then v
becomes the root.
So what does the
picture look like?
We've got v at the
root of it's ox tree.
Then we've got things
in the left subtree
which have smaller depth.
And then we've got things
in the right subtree of tree
which have bigger depth.
Depth bigger than v. So we
just pulled to the root.
So in the represented tree
what we have is a path v. These
are things of smaller depth
these things of larger depth.
Now, if you look at the
definition of preferred child,
when we access v, v now no
longer has a preferred child.
This preferred
child is now none.
If you look at
this picture, this
is a preferred path, currently,
v has a preferred child.
We want to get rid of that.
That's our first operation.
First thing we want to do
is get rid of that edge.
It's no longer a preferred edge.
So that essentially
corresponds to this edge
because that's the connection
from v to deeper things.
I mean in fact, this
node right below us
let's call it x is right here.
It's the smallest
depth among the nodes
with larger depth than v.
But if we kind of
kill that connection,
then, now, this path is its
own thing, the part below v,
separate from v and above.
So that's what we're
going to do first.
Remove these preferred child.
And I'm going to elaborate
exactly the point arithmetic
that makes that happen.
This is the kind of tedious
part of, or really any point
of machine data structure.
This is going to all work on a
point of machine, by the way.
OK, so basically I'm
obliterating the edge.
So I'm going to make this
vertex here, have a path parent
pointer to v and otherwise
obliterate this edge.
It will no longer has a parent,
v no longer has a right child.
So it's going to be v has a
left thing and no right pointer.
But this separate tree is
going to a parent pointer to v.
This is, of course,
if it exists.
If v.right is nothing already,
then you don't do any of this.
But if there is a right pointer
then you've got to do this.
So this is the place
where we're going
to set path parents,
pretty obvious stuff.
The only thing to check
is that this is really
in the right place.
This thing is the root
of this ox tree, which
is where the parent pointer
path parent supposed to be,
and it points to v meaning,
that the parent of x
is v in the represented tree.
And that's exactly
what this picture is.
This is the represented
tree parent of x is v,
and so that's the correct
definition of pat parent.
Cool.
OK, now the fun part.
Now, we're going to
walk up the tree.
We've seen everything on the
outline except this heavy light
decomposition.
We'll come to that soon.
OK, so now we're going
to walk up the tree
and add new preferred
child pointers.
This is the one that we
had to remove because it's
the stuff below v. But up the
path, if we walk up to the root
here, to the left
most node of v then
there's a path
parent from there,
we want to make that not a path
parent but a regular parent.
Because that right
now, is living
in its own little
preferred path that we
want that preferred path to
extend all the way to the root,
by the definition of a
child after doing an access.
So we're going to do a loop
until v path parent is none.
I'm going to let w
be v's path parent.
save some writing.
And then we're going to splay w.
OK, I think at this point,
I should draw a picture.
So many pictures to draw.
So we have, let's say, a
node w as a child v. This
is the represented tree.
That's some other child x
and I can have many children.
Let's suppose that, right now,
the preferred child from w
is x.
It's not v because we just
followed a path parent pointer
to go from v's path, which is
something here, to w's path.
So w's path is going to
be something like this.
So it goes to some
other guy x, we
want change that that pointer.
Instead of being that,
we want to go here.
That's in the represented tree.
Now what does this look like
in the tree of ox trees?
W lives in some thing.
w's there, x's its
successor in there,
so maybe it's like a
right child or whatever,
somewhere else in the tree.
And then separately we've
already built this thing.
v it has a left child, it has
no right child because there's
nothing deeper than v in
its own preferred path.
And then we have a path parent
pointer that goes like this.
I want to fix.
That the first thing I'm
going to do is splay w,
so the w is in the
root of its own tree.
So then it's going
to look like w.
It's going to have a left child,
left subtree, right subtree.
X is going to be its
successor so it's
the leftmost thing in there.
And we still have v with its
left child and this pointer.
It's not in the tree.
So if two ox trees, now I want
to basically merge these two ox
trees, but also get
rid of this stuff.
Just like we did
up here actually.
First, I have to destroy
this preferred child
and then make a new
one, which is v.
So how do I do it?
I just replace the
right pointer from w
to be v instead of whatever
this thing is that's it.
So say, switch w's preferred
child to be v. And what we do
is say w, first we clip
off the existing guy,
we say this node's w.rights path
parent is now going to be w.
We still want to have some way
to get from here back up to w,
just like we did up here.
This code is going to look very
similar to these two lines.
We set it's parents to none.
And we set w.right.
Up, here we set it to none.
Now we know it
actually needs to be v.
And then we set
the reverse pointer
so v's parent is now w and v
no longer has a path parent.
So essentially the reverse
of these operations.
So we remove this
preferred child pointer
and we add this one in.
So the new picture will be,
we have w has its left subtree
just like before.
It's right subtree is now
v with its left subtree.
And then we also have this
other tree hanging out.
Not directly connected except
by path parent pointer.
So whereas before, v was
linked in with the path parent
pointer, now this thing is
linked to in the parent pointer
and sort of the
primary connection,
the white connection
is direct from w to v.
And that's exactly
what corresponds
to clipping off this portion
of the preferred path
and concatenating on this
portion of the preferred path.
More or less clear?
You can double
check this at home
but that's what we need to, do.
To go back and forth
between these two worlds.
The represented world
and the tree of our world
is doing the right thing.
Again you can check that
this path parent is, indeed,
the right thing.
It's essentially saying
the parent of x equals
w, which is, indeed, the case.
That left most thing
here, its parent is w.
Cool last thing we do is
kind of a lame way to say it,
but I want to splay v
within its ox tree Now,
v is a child of the root.
So this just means
rotate v. So what
it's going to look like
is v becomes the root,
it's left child is w, that
left child is whatever,
that right child is whatever.
V will still have no right
child because v is the deepest
node in it's preferred path.
So there's nothing
deeper than it.
There's nothing
to the right of v.
So these two
triangles go to here.
Of course, there's still the
old triangle with x in it,
and it's still going to prefer
it's still going to point to w.
But we want v to
eventually end up
to be the very, very root so
I'd like to make the root again
after I did this concatenation.
And so there you go you can
think of this as a second splay
if you want or as a
rotation, either way.
And now we're going to loop.
OK, the one thing I
didn't make explicit
is that when we do a splay,
or when we do a rotation,
you have to carry along
the path parent pointer.
So like right now,
sorry, in this picture,
w has some path parent
pointer because it's
the root of its ox tree.
After we do the
rotation, v is the root
and so it's going to have
the parent path parent point.
Or you can just define rotate
to preserve that information.
So now v has some new path
parent and we do the loop.
As long as it is not
there's something there,
we're going to splay
it stick them together.
Repeat, the number
of times we repeat,
is equal to the number of
preferred child changes.
So that's how we're going
to analyze the thing.
How many times does a child
have to change in this world.
OK, clear, more or
less that is that's
the hard the hard
operation access.
One thing to note is v will
have no right child at the end,
and it will be the root
of the tree of ox trees.
Why the tree of ox trees?
When we stop, we
have no path parent.
That means we are
the overall root.
So that's the end.
Cool now let me
tell you how to do--
first, I'll do the
queries, and then I'll
do the updates, link-cut.
Cut Make tree, I'm pretty
sure, if you all think
you know how did you make tree.
So let's start with find root.
So for find root, first thing
we're going to do is access v.
So what that gives us is v, no
right child, some left child.
This is v's ox tree, but the
roots of the overall tree
is right here.
This is r.
Because, in the
end, we know that,
the mean the root ox tree
always contains the root
node of the tree, and the
access operation makes it also
contain v So what's the highest
node in that path from r to v?
Well, it's the left
most node in the thing.
So you just block left
to find the root r.
And then, we are going to do
one more thing, which splay r.
If we didn't splay
r, we'd be in trouble
because this is a splay tree.
If you say this r might be
extremely deep in the tree.
And so if you just repeatedly
said, find root of v,
find v for the same
v, you don't want
to have to walk down linear
length path every single time.
So we're going to splay it
every time we touch the root,
so that very soon r will be
near the root of the tree of ox
trees, and so this
operation will become fast.
So amortized it will
always be order log n.
But we need to do that.
OK that's fine root.
Let's do half aggregate.
Of aggregates
basically the same.
Actually, even easier.
First thing we do like
all of our operations,
is access v, so we
get that picture.
So remember what
this corresponds to?
This is an ox tree that
represents a path ending in v
So this is in the
represented tree.
And the goal of a
path aggregate is
to compute the min or the max
or to some of those things.
So I basically
have this tree that
represents exactly the
things I care about,
and I just need to do a sum
or a min or a max or whatever.
So easy way to do it is
augment all the ox trees
to have subtree
size, subtree sums,
or mins or maxes, whatever
operations you care about.
And so then it's just a return
v.subtree min max, whatever.
You have to have to check
when we do link-cuts
that it's easy to maintain
augmentation like this,
but it is.
And now this, the
subtree aggregations
are relative to
your own ox tree.
You don't go deeper.
In fact, there's
no way to go deeper
because if you look
at the structure,
there's no way to go down.
We store these path
parents, but we
can't afford to store path
children because a node may
have a zillion path children.
So it's kind of
awkward to store them.
we don't have to because
this aggregation is just
within the ox tree.
That's exactly
what we care about
because it represents that
path and nothing more.
So you see, access makes
our life pretty darn easy.
Once that path is preferred,
we can do whatever
we need to with that path.
We can compute aggregations,
the root, anything pretty
much instantly once
we have access.
OK, I claim also link
and cut are really easy.
So let me show you that.
So let's start with cut.
First thing we do, you
guessed it, access v. So
think about this
picture a little bit.
So we have v, have this stuff.
What this corresponds
to, this is the ox tree
in the represented tree.
This is a path
from the root to v.
And our goal in
the cut operation
is to separate v from its
parent in the represented tree.
So we want to remove this
edge above v. That basically
corresponds to this edge.
Connection from v to all the
things less deep than it.
So this is the preferred path.
Of course, in reality, there
is some subtree down here,
and that's going to correspond
to things that are linked here
by path parent pointers.
So they'll come along for the
ride, because what they know
is they're attached to v.
And so all we need to do
is delete this edge
and we're done.
It's kind of crazy,
but it works.
So what we do, say, v
left the parent is none.
The left is none.
That's it.
Gone.
That edge has disappeared.
What will be left with
is v all by itself.
/ Has no left child,
no right child.
It still has some things that
link into it via path parent
pointers.
But v is alone in its ox
tree after you do a cut.
This thing will now live
in a separate world.
In particular, this node
becomes the new root
of the tree of ox
trees for this tree.
after we do the cut,
there's two trees.
So there's two
trees of ox trees.
There's the one with v,
v will remain the root
of its tree of ox trees.
And the other one,
this thing called x,
becomes its own root of
its own tree of ox trees.
So there's nothing else to do.
It doesn't need a parent
pointer because it's not
linked to anything above it.
The end.
OK, I corresponds to
some node up here.
Kind of the median node.
So there you go.
That's a cut.
It's like super short code.
You have to stare
at it for a while
and make sure it does all the
right things, but it does.
How about a link?
Well first thing we do on a
link, is access v and access w.
These don't interfere
with each other
because precondition
is that v and w are
in different trees of ox trees.
They're indifferent
represented trees.
So they're completely
independent.
The result will
be that we have--
should be consistent --so
ox trees are on the left.
We're going to have w, is
going to have a left thing.
We're going to have v claim
all by itself because remember
what a link does?
It's right here, v is
assumed to be a root node.
So if you do an access
on the root node,
then the path from the root
to v is a very short path.
It is just v itself.
So the ox tree
containing v, will just
be v itself when you
do x as v. Yeah, so
this is the picture
in represented space.
And so we access v,
we're going to have this.
Of course, there's
stuff pointing into it.
We're at access w, so it's
going to look like this.
And then this path is going
to be what's over here.
And there's, of
course, more stuff
linked from below into those.
Our goal is to add this
edge between v and w, which
corresponds to
adding this change.
So that's what
we're going to do.
V.left left equals w.
W.parent equals v.
If you want, you could instead
make v the right child of w.
And that looks much more sane.
I like it this way because
it looks kind of insane.
This is not unbalanced
or anything.
But splay trees will fix it
so you don't have to worry.
This is the carefree
approach to data structuring.
And you just leave it to
the analysis to make sure.
Everything here is going
to be log n amortized.
But you can check this is doing
the right thing, because v
is deeper than w, right?
So we had this path from
the root over here to w.
We're extending the
path by one node, v,
and so v should be to
the right of everything.
So either it goes that
here is that right child
w that would also work, or
would make it the parent of w
on the right that works.
It's in the correct order,
binary search tree order.
OK?
So you see length and
links and cuts are easy.
In fact, the most
complicated was
find root where we had
to do a walk and splay,
but basically, everything
reduces to access.
If access is fast,
all these operations
will be fast because they
spend essentially constant time
plus a constant
number of accesses.
Except for find root.
It also doesn't splay.
But we're going to show
displays are efficient as,
well as part of access, because
access does a ton of splays.
So this is log n
amortize, surely
one splay is log n amortized.
And indeed, that
will be the case.
AUDIENCE: Splay as access.
PROFESSOR: Here, I'm treating
splaying not as an access.
So I'm going to define access
to mean calling this function.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK so over
here, access first splays v
and displays various things.
It might not splay r.
AUDIENCE: No, I'm saying, do
you call access r [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh good.
That might simplify my analysis.
I'll just change this
line to access r.
Good, why not?
Yeah, that seems
like a good way.
OK, I think you could do that.
It might simplify,
conceptually, what's going on.
The one thing I find
annoying about it's just--
it's an aesthetic, let's say.
So here, I was talking
about the last access.
And if you define lost access
to mean access, that's fine.
But also another intuitive
notion of the last access,
is the last time it was given to
any of these functions cut link
find root path aggregate.
And so r is not really
given to the function.
Of course, it's the
output of find roots,
so maybe you think
of that as an access.
You could say find root
is accessing the root.
Either way, this
should work either way,
but I think I like that.
You just have to
redefine things a little.
OK, let's do some analysis.
This is the data structure.
Algorithms are all up there
in they're gory detail.
This is.
Of course.
goriest.
I can now erase the, API.
Makes me think of
Google versus Oracle.
And then following that case?
Yeah, it's interesting.
OK pretty clear
this implementation
is much more significant
than the API, but anyway.
If
First goal is to
prove log squared.
This is just like a warm up.
This is actually
trivial at this point.
We've done all the work to
do a lot of squared bound.
In fact, you just
replace the slay tree
with a red-black
tree, and you know
that each of these
operations is Log n.
All displays that we do, I
mean, you can do essentially
like a splay in a balance
binary [INAUDIBLE] tree,
you can still move
it to the root.
You can still maintain it
temporarily and maintain
the height is order log n.
That's one way to view it.
Or you can observe the
splay tree analysis
that gives you log n,
which we haven't actually
covered in this class.
Still applies in this scenario.
Even though it's not
one splay a tree.
It's a bunch of trees.
You can show each of the
splays is order log n.
So what that gives you is that--
so we have lets just say
it's order log n amortized
per splay, a few splay trees
or use regular balancer
trees is definitely log n.
So then if we do m operations,
it's going to cost --we're not
actually going to be done--
order log n times
m plus total number
of preferred child changes.
This bound should be clear,
because every operation reduces
to accesses plus
constant amount of work.
Maybe one more splay a
splay is just another log n.
And the total number of
preferred child changes
comes from this access thing.
We're doing one splay per
preferred child change.
So that thing is
reasonable, you just
take it, multiply by
log n, we're done.
So the remaining thing is,
at this point, just claim.
Total number of preferred
trial changes is order m log n.
So if you take this
whole thing, divide by m,
you get log squared amortize.
So that sounds kind
of lame, log square
is not such a good bound,
but it's a warm up.
In fact, we need to
prove this anyway.
We need this for
the log n analysis.
So first thing
I'm going to do is
prove total number of preferred
child changes is log squared.
Before I do that, I need
heavy-light decomposition.
So to prove, this we're going to
use heavy-light decomposition.
And this I think, is where
things get pretty cool.
So heavy-light
decomposition, this
is another way to decompose
a tree into paths.
So heavy-light
decomposition is, again,
going to apply to
the represented tree.
Not the tree of ox trees.
It's like an intrinsic thing.
It's very simple we define
the size of the node
to be the number of
nodes in that subtree.
We've done this
many times, I think.
And then, we're going
to call an edge from v
to its parent heavy or light.
It's heavy if the size
of v is more than half
of the size of its parent.
And, otherwise,
it's called light.
OK, so we have parent
and sub child v
has loads of other children.
I just want to know, is the
heaviest of all your children?
That's one way to define it.
But, in, particular
is a bigger than half
of the total weight of p?
So there might not
be any heavy child
according to this definition.
Maybe it's nicely
evenly balanced.
Everybody's got a third.
But if somebody has got bigger
than 1/2, I call it heavy.
Everybody else is light.
So there's going to be, at most,
one heavy edge from every node.
Therefore, heavy edges decompose
your world into path's.
Heavy paths decompose the tree.
Nodes, every node lives
in some heavy path.
It may be node has no heavy
childs, but, at most, one.
This may seem kind of silly,
but in fact, because your maybe
all edges are light.
This might not do
anything, every node
is in its own path, that's
actually a really good case,
light edges are good.
Why are they good?
Because then the size of
v is at most half the size
of its parent.
I mean, every time you
follow a light edge,
the size of your subtree
went down by a factor of 2.
How many times is
going to happen?
Log n times.
Start with everything at
the root, as you walk down,
if you're decreasing your
side effect or two every time,
you can only follow log .
Light edges.
This is what we call the
light depth of a node.
This is the number of light
edges on a root to the path.
And it is always,
at most, log n.
Now, remember heavy
edges could be huge.
Maybe you follow, maybe
your tree is a path.
Then every edge is heavy.
And you n of them to
get from the root of v.
So we can't bound the
number of heavy edges.
But the number of light
we can bound as log n.
This is where heavy light
to composition is useful.
So you've got preferred
path composition.
Our Or data structure, we're
not going to change it.
It's still following
the preferred path
the decomposition.
But our analysis is going
to think about which edges
are heavy and which are light.
In general, an edge can
have four different states.
It can be preferred
or not preferred.
And it can be preferred
or not preferred,
it could be heavy or light.
All four of those
combinations are possible,
because one of them has to
do with the access sequence,
the other has to do with
the structure of the tree.
These are basically
orthogonal to each other.
OK, so let's maybe go here.
So next thing I'm going to do
is use heavy light decomposition
to analyze total number of
preferred child changes,
by looking at not only
whether an edge is preferred
or not, but whether
it is heavy or light.
We're going to get an order m
log n bound on preferred child
changes.
So here's the big idea.
In order for a preferred
child to change,
I mean when you change
for a child of one node
from this to this, I'm
going to think of this edge
as being destroyed
from its preferredness,
and this one is being created
in it's preferredness.
OK, so of course, if we could
count preferred edge equations,
that would be basically the
same as preferred child changes.
Or we could count preferred
edge destructions,
that would be basically, the
same as the number of changes.
OK, so that's the idea.
If you ignore this part, or
look at pilferage equations
or prefer it is destructions.
But then I also care
about whether that edge
is light or heavy.
So it turns out for
the light edges,
it's going to be easier to
talk about the creations
or to bound the creations.
For heavy edges is
going to be easier
to bound the destructions.
If I do both of those and
add them up, that in total
is, basically, the number
of preferred edge changes
according to whether
there is light or heavy.
You need to add in a
little bit more because
and edge might get created
but never destroyed.
And if it's heavy, then
it won't get counted here.
Or an edge might get
destroyed because it
exists originally,
never got created
but it got destroyed
over the operations.
And if it was light, then
it wouldn't be counted here.
So just add on n plus
1 for all the edges
might get a bonus point.
But, otherwise,
this will bound it,
it's going to look at
light edge creations--
creations, light preferred edge
creations, heavy preferred edge
distructions.
And it can be destroyed because
it becomes no longer heavy
or no longer preferred.
And it can be created
because it becomes light
or it becomes preferred and
was already the other one.
OK, so all we need
to do is think
about, in all these operations,
access link-cut, just
the updates.
So access link/cut.
How can this change?
So let's start with access.
So access.
The hard one.
Well, there's all
this implementation,
which is dealing with
the tree of ox trees,
but really, an access
does a very simple thing.
It makes the path from
the root to be preferred.
That's its goal.
So there's the root, it's
to v, this becomes preferred
whether it was before or not.
Some of it was before
some of it wasn't.
So some of these might
be on newly preferred.
It does not change which
edges are heavy or light.
It does not change the
structure of the tree
when you do an access.
Only link/cut changed the
structure of the tree.
So it makes some of
these edges preferred.
What that means, of course,
is that some other edges
used to be preferred and
are no longer preferred.
Those are the preferred
child changes.
So if we look at
this, first concern
is that we're creating
new preferred edges,
so maybe we create some
new light preferred edges.
How many new light
preferred edges
could we create along this path?
Most log n.
Whatever the light depth
of v is as an upper bound.
So make, at most, log
and, like preferred edges,
because they all live
on a single path.
And it would be really
hard to bound how many
heavy preferred edges we make.
But we don't have to.
We don't have to worry about
heavy preferred edges being
destroyed.
Now, those edges
could be these ones.
These edges used to be
preferred, now they're not.
If they were heavy, then
I have to pay for them.
But the number of these
edges is equal to,
or is at most, the
number of these edges.
I mean, if this edge
was heavy, every node
has only one heavy down pointer.
So if this edge is heavy hanging
off, then this one is light.
We know there's only
log n light edges here.
So the number of
heavy edges coming off
here can also be most log n,
So destroy, at most, log
n heavy preferred edges.
Yeah In some sense,
we don't even really
are about the word
preferred here.
But, of course, we're not
making them, light so anyway.
Is that clear?
Now, there's actually one more
edge that could change which
is, there used to be a preferred
edge from v, now there isn't.
We destroyed that in the very
beginning of the operation.
So maybe plus 1 that might have
destroyed one more heavy edge.
But overall order log n.
So, actually, really
easy to analyze access.
Any questions about that?
OK, link/cut not
much to say here.
Yeah, so link/cut don't really
change what's preferred.
I'm analyzing-- I'm going
to think about what link
does after it accesses v and w.
Because access we've
already analyzed.
So link is just
these two operations
which add a single pointer.
So if you look at what that's
doing in the represented tree,
which was v was the
route and we made
it to be a new child w, which
lived in some tree over here.
That's in the represented
tree, what happens.
What happens is
that w gets heavier.
I guess also this get's heavier.
All the nodes on this route
to w path get heavier.
That's all that happens
in terms of heavy, light.
Preferred paths don't change.
It's just about heavy
and light changing.
OK, in fact, this will
be a preferred path
from the root to v because
we just accessed those guys.
So we're heavying edges,
which means you might create
new heavy preferred edges.
But we don't care about heavy
preferred edges being created.
We only care about
them being destroyed.
So has anything changed?
Well, there might have been a
heavy edge hanging off of here.
Is that possible?
Yeah, so this might turn
light, because this one
became heavier.
So this edge might
become light, which
means we might have
potentially lost--
this could have been
preferred before.
It wasn't preferred,
so who cares?
If we've already
done the accesses,
the edges are already
not preferred.
So not a big deal.
So can anything happen?
I think not.
Some of the edges on the
path might become heavy,
but we don't care because
they are preferred.
Some of the edges off the
path might become light,
but we don't care because
they're not preferred.
Done.
So this actually costs zero
in just analyzing number
of preferred child changes.
Cuts, not quite so simple.
When we do a cut,
we're lightning stuff.
The path from the root to
v in the represented tree,
when we line up there,
becomes lighter,
because we cut off that
whole subtree containing v.
So we might create light
preferred edges on that path.
And that's something we
actually want to count.
we count number of light
preferred edges created.
But, again, they're on a
path so it's, at most, log n
Most log n light
preferred edges created.
We don't care about edges
hanging off that path
because they're not
preferred anymore,
so it's nothing to talk about.
So that's it.
That proves m log n
preferred child changes.
It's amortized because we're
doing this creation/destruction
business.
This thing is worst case log n
per operation, this quantity.
But when you sum it
up, then you actually
get about the number of
preferred child changes
overall.
So if you plug that
into this bound,
we get a log squared m bound.
Big deal.
But with a little
bit more work, we
can actually get a log n bound.
For this, we need
to actually know
a little bit about
splay tree analysis.
I didn't cover in Lecture Six.
You probably would have
forgotten it by now anyway.
So let me give you
what little you need
to know about splay analysis.
First, I need to define a
slightly weird quantity.
It's kind of like
the weight of a node.
It's a capital W, but
a little bit weird.
OK, now we're thinking
about the tree of ox trees.
For the analysis we need that.
It's a tree of splay trees.
And what I'm looking at, is
in that tree of ox trees,
how many nodes are
in the subtree of v?
That's what I'm
going to call wv .
Whereas size of v was thinking
in the represented tree.
So this is a totally
different world.
Here, we're thinking about
the tree of ox trees.
So one way you can
rewrite this count
as the sum of all nodes w in
the ox tree containing v. It's
a weird notation, but look at
all the other nodes in the ox
tree--
is that right?
Sorry.
No.
I should say w in v's
subtree in v's ox tree.
It's awkward to say.
What I mean is there is an
ox tree containing a node v,
and I want to look in that
subtree I'll know as w.
Just within the ox tree though.
And for all those nodes,
I take 1 plus the size
of ox trees hanging off.
So total number of nodes.
And when I say
hanging off I mean
via pathed parent pointers.
So down here, there are
trees, add up all their sizes
total number of nodes in
them, add one for w itself,
that's another way
of writing this.
I'll just mention that this
part is what's normally
considered in splay trees.
This is a bonus thing that,
basically, doesn't matter.
I'll justify that in a second.
So we define a
potential function
for our amortization fee, which
is sum over all nodes v of log
this quantity wv, this thing.
So just think of this
as an abstract quantity,
which for every node it has
some number associated with it.
Splay trees allow you to assign
arbitrary weight to every node,
use this potential function,
and prove abound --which
is called the access lemma
The access lemma says is that,
for this potential
function, the amortized cost
of doing a splay
operation splay of v,
is, at most, three times
log w of root of v's ox tree
minus log w of v plus 1.
OK, so this is something
called the access Lemma
It's used to prove, for
example, that splay trees have
log n performance amortize.
It's also used to
prove that they
have a working set
bound, which you
may recall from Lecture Six.
But we never actually mentioned
the access lemma It's a tool.
It's an analysis tool.
This works no matter
how the w's are defined.
And remember, we're
thinking of splaying just
within a single ox tree.
So the size of the
ox trees hanging off
don't change during a splay.
They just come
along for the ride.
So the old analysis
of splay trees
I haven't proved
this lemma to you.
But it still applies
in this setting.
And given my lack of time.
I will just say in
words, the way you prove
this lemma is very simple.
You do you analyze each
operation of display
separately there's a zig-zag
case in a zigzag case.
And you argue that every time
you do such an operation,
you pay three times
a log of w of v
after the operation minus log
of wv before the operation.
So you just see how wv
changes when it goes up
after you do display
operation, and turns out it's
the most three
times log of that.
And it has to do with
concavity of log n.
It's just basic checking.
Once you have that you
get a telescoping sum.
Each operation is log
w new minus long w old.
Those cancel, in turn, until
you get the final log w of v,
minus the original log w of v.
The final log w is whatever--
I mean, v becomes the root and
so it has everybody below it.
So that's the axis lemma.
So assuming the
access lemma, I want
to prove to you a log n bound.
Maybe over here OK,
another thing to note,
when we change preferred
children, it does not affect w.
W defined on the
tree of ox trees.
If you turn a path
parent pointer
into a regular parent pointer
or vice versa, It doesn't care.
It looks the same from the
tree of ox trees' perspective.
All that changes, all that
matters is when you do splays
this stuff happens.
But the splay analysis
tells us how splays behave.
So we're kind of good.
If you look at what we did
over here, when we splayed v,
then we splayed w, then we did
a little bit of manipulation
which doesn't matter
in this analysis.
And then we splayed
v one more time.
How much does that cost
according to the access lemma.
It's basically going
to cost you order log
w of little w minus
log w of v plus 1,
because well is it clear?
When we do the first splay
of v going up to the root
that cost log of w of
the whole tree containing
b minus longer wv.
But if you just
look at log, I mean,
w is higher than the root of
v. So if we take a log of w
this the whole thing from w
downwards minus log wv, that
includes the cost that we did
for the initial splay of v.
Then when we played w, well
that's basically the same thing
but the next level up.
So if you look at log of w
minus log of w of next level up,
that's what it's going
to cost this splay w.
To splay v again, will
again cost this bound.
The point is, we sum this up
over all the preferred child
changes.
And what we get is a
telescoping scum again.
Same as in the display analysis.
So we end up with order log w
of everything, which an n minus,
I guess, the log of
w of the original v,
-but we don't really
care about that--
plus the number of
preferred child changes.
And now we're golden because
before, the obvious bound was
number preferred child
changes times again, now
it's number of
preferred time changes
plus log n for an entire access.
And so we pay log n here.
We already know the amortize
number preferred child changes
is log n per operation.
So overall the amortize
cost per operation is log n.
And we're done.
So I'll just mention the worst
case version of link-cut trees
instead of the amortize
splay based version.
They actually store the
heavy light decomposition.
They don't use preferred path
to decomposition at all, which
makes all the algorithms messy.
But you can just maintain the
heavy [? likely ?] composition
position dynamically as
the tree is changing,
and then you use a kind
of weight balanced trees,
like we saw in the
strings lecture, where
the depth of a node is sort
of related to log of its size
or inversely related I guess.
So you try to put all the
heavy things near the root,
because they're more
likely to be accessed.
And then you guarantee that
the overall tree of ox trees
has long n depth by skewing
each of the end of the ox trees
to match.
So it can be done but all
the operations are messier,
because you no longer have the
convenience of preferred paths
to make it easy to
link/cut things.